L'Europe des Nations,
euh, telle que la voulait le général de Gaulle,
donc ça veut dire
moins d'Europe, pas 1 sortie, mais moins d'Europe,
moins de traités,
moins de construction, à à 26, à 27, à plus, et on,
c'est, c'est, c'est ça que
vous allez défendre si vous êtes élu,
si on veut voir l'agriculture française crevée
comme elle crève actuellement,
les artisans, les commerçants,
les services publics à la française,
y a plus rien qui tient,
même pas la médecine,
euh ni les hôpitaux,
l'instruction publique, rien.
Et bien il y a qu'à continuer.
Moi, je suis pour que la France
retrouve sa voix dans le concert des
nations qu'on a dit général.
Et je veux qu'ensuite nous ayons,
euh. 1 véritable relation de partenariat,
mais avec chacun
responsable chez lui,
rendant compte de son électorat,
pendant 1 communauté de commune.